die Aufgabe in unserem Konvergenz vor
Ort bezahlen die Menschenrettung die
Rettung von verschütterten Personen und
wahrscheinlich auch tragischerweise die
Bergung von Toten genau unser
Vorkommando ist vor Ort Stärke acht Mann
ebenfalls der konvergenzkommandant ist
dort neuer linkenberg er hat jetzt der
bereits den Flughafen
erreicht und unser Einsatzraum wird sein
der Großraum gasiantip eine Stadt im
Süden eine eine Stadt mit 2 Millionen
Einwohnern und nördlich davon befindet
sich das Epizentrum und die Lage dort
stellt sich als nicht sehr gut da es war
ein starkes Beben und die Besonderheit
dort war das auch dass es auch nach dem
gegeben hat und dass diese ebenso fast
gleich stark waren
ist vor allem die Aufgabe zum einen das
Kontingent gesund zu erhalten und auch
der anderen Seite sollten Probleme sein
sollen die Hunde natürlich versorgt
werden sollten kleinere Verletzungen
auftreten werden die vor Ort umgehend
versorgt damit man die Hunde
einsatzfähig halten kann